- Wait so, we all made some choices
in the nineties with fashion.
So what are, so I'm gonna start with you,
what are some of your best worst moments,
we all have 'em.
What, I'm gonna start
with you, you're welcome.
(laughing)
- Thank you, you're welcome.
- I like to put you on this spot
'cause you're a thinker.
- One of the worst things is
when we first broke in Europe,
we would go over there
and we'd spend sometimes
three months at a time
and you go to a magazine shoot
and they want to get as much
content from you as possible.
So you do like 10 different looks.
And this one look, we were in the UK
we were doing a cover
for Smash Hits magazine
and they gave these shiny silk shirts.
- Good start.
- And we're all holding disco balls.
- I remember that.
- Yeah.
- That's probably one of the worst--
- You're wearing silk
shirts holding balls.
That's awesome.
- Yep
and our makeup was so light.
Our makeup was really,
really like silvery.
Those were in, in the nineties
- Yeah.
- but it just didn't look good
and we all had way too much makeup.
- Oh yeah.
- I bet it looked great.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- At that age
we didn't need makeup then, we were young.
Why, I don't know why we had makeup on,
but they put makeup on and it looked crazy
and that's one of the worst and.
Yeah.
- Yep.
- So.
- Look, that's when they colored my hair.
- I don't know what's
- You guys are like
- happening right now.
- babies right now.
- Yeah.
- They colored my hair red.
I was like for real,
- I love that.
- Hey.
- I love that was our Caesar haircut.
- Yeah, that was when
the Caesar haircuts were a
thing back in the nineties, man.
- Caesar haircuts
- Caesar haircuts.
is that what it's called?
- Yeah, the little.
- I didn't know it was called that.
- Bangs.
- Caesar.
- And you know what that was called?
For the people that don't
know, that's called a landline.
- Yep.
- That was a telephone.
- A landline.
- Actually a landline.
- I always think of Roseanne.
I always think of Roseanne the show
she'd like have that phone everywhere.
- Oh yeah.